It was way past our bedtime,
but I needed a little late night snack,
and I was violently craving some strawberry sorbet,
but I was too tired to make it,
so lucky offered to make me some.
He started off by roughly chopping half a lemon
and adding that to a blender.
Once that was in the blender,
he combined that with some sugar as well
and blended that until it was all combined and good to go.
Trust me, you need to leave the lemon peel on the lemon.
It makes such a difference in how the sorbet taste.
Then he moved on to washing some strawberries.
He make sure to wash them really good
because of all the videos he keeps seeing about dirty strawberries.
After they were thoroughly washed,
he cut the tops off and then sliced them in half.
He used about a pound of strawberries.
I don't know whether it's his ADHD,
but watching him cut things and arrange it is
one of the cutest things to me.
Once all of our ingredients were prepped,
he transferred the strawberries over to a blender,
added the lemon and sugar mixture that he pureed earlier,
and a squeeze of half a lemon,
blended that up until there were no chunks visible and it was smooth.
Before pouring it into our ice cream.
Turner let that go on medium speed,
and once it got a little bit more solid,
he turned the speed down to a slower speed.
Let that turn for about 20 minutes
until it reach the consistency he wanted
before spooning some into a bowl for me.
The rest of the ice cream,
he just transfer that over to the freezer.
At this point,
I needed my sorbet,
so I came to try it,
and it was exactly what I was craving.